the Joe Rogan experience you're at the
top of the heap in this championship
realm right and to train with people
that are bigger than you or to take
chances like that like there's no other
sport that would have that yeah you know
yeah and it's like the lack of women as
well you know because even if I'm
training with like a bantamweight if
it's a woman like it's not as dangerous
as training with like some of the bigger
guys like the like guys and girls are
kind of like different sizes like if I'm
if I'm training with a guy who fights at
1:15 he's gonna be like four foot tall
you know so it's a it's like the weight
distribution is different but like I
don't know something about I guess
training with women like the strength
the the force that's coming at you
versus the force you're giving to them
there I just feel like it's a lot safer
to train with women oh for sure for sure
but some people think that the opposite
is that if you train with men like say
if you were trained with a bunch of
bantamweight men yeah they would be
bigger than you yeah they'd be strong
with you but you get used to that and
then you'd be used to men and then when
you fight with women they would seem
smaller and weaker yeah that's that was
my old like theory so when I was at like
my little gym in New York I was only
training with guys like oh the girls I
would come in they weren't at my level
and that's the same story that most
girls in the UFC have you know they were
at the top of their heap they were like
the baddest girl in the gym you know
beating up all the other girls and hang
with the guys and that was me so it
wasn't until I got on top that I
realized like everyone has the same
exact background so everyone's tough
because they were training with guys and
you start to underestimate like how
tough a girl's gonna be in there like
when you're fighting like tooth and nail
like you know to the death is basically
like what you're doing in the cage until
the ref pulls you off you know and then
it's all hugs but like when you're given
like a hundred percent in the cage it
feels like just as strong as a guy you
know so it's good to like still have
those checks
bounces like okay like yeah maybe she's
not as strong as the guys I trained with
but she is going as hard as she can
or she's defending it as hard as she can
or you know she's taking my punches that
I thought like oh if I drop this guy
with this punch then this girl is gonna
get dropped too and it's not the case
like she's just a tougher tougher so
it's it's like a weird thing where like
you have like I don't know you have
different stats like stacked in some
areas that guys don't and then they have
stats stacked in areas that women don't
so it's like it's like if I was it's
like if I was like a bantamweight guy
who only trained with like like
heavyweights
you know like you're gonna be faster
you're gonna have like you're probably
gonna be more technical just because you
have to train with people that big so if
you [ __ ] up a technique it's not gonna
work but those guys are still gonna be
bigger and stronger and be able to like
muscle you hold you down that kind of
thing so I feel like that's like a
similar difference but ticket was
striking right like with with grappling
there's some really little guys that are
impossible to tap they just develop
really crazy technique yeah but what's
striking there's only so much you could
do you know if you're a lightweight guy
you're not sparring with Francis and
gone Oh er he better be really really
really nice exactly hey or you better be
nice it's gonna work well no I've
actually like been told off for going
hard with the heavy weights like when I
was like you know just coming up like
super green and like I was just like I'm
gonna kill everyone in the gym there's a
little thing like running at you
throwing over hands and like it went it
land like my coach would be like hey you
got it you gotta relax cuz like you're
landing over hands on this big guy if he
does the same to you he's gonna put you
out and I was like [ __ ] I never thought
about that cuz I just assumed like he
wouldn't yeah well now I'm at that I
just assumed that like me landing a hard
punch on a heavy weight isn't gonna hurt
as much as me landing a hard punch on
someone closer to my size Frisch it
makes sense not like their neck is
bigger yeah
so yeah but it's still like if the guy
is getting rot then right that's if he
gets mad and far as well yeah yeah if
he's getting his head turned and that's
what like it your chin can only take so
much so it's like it's a lot less than
like if I was throwing a body shot you
know like that's it's a little easier to
be mean right
[Applause]